For this exercise, you need to create a similar scatter
plot that had friend count mean against age with months. We'll
use ggplot to create our figure. I'll pass age with months
to x, and I'll pass friend count mean to y. And
then I just need to remember to wrap this in AES.
Now comes the data frame. I need to be careful that
I don't use pseudo Facebook users, since I really want this
data frame that we just created. Now that I've got my
data frame, I need to subset it. I'll only take the users
whose age with months is less then 71. Then, I'll tell ggplot
what type of geom I want, in this case geom live. So
here's our much nosier plot, a friend count mean versus age with months.